Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome to 'Grab the Bottle'.
Now, this game is absolutely bizarre.
It is one hundred percent WEIRD,
but that doesn't mean I'm not on board with the concept,
because you'll see why it's weird very soon.
Oh, don't you worry. Oh, don't you worry.
HUH. That baby looks so old! (laughs)
That baby looks ancient!
(reading) Your goal is to get to the bottle and grab it. Start the game by pressing 'Grab' and maneuver to the bottle. Avoid hitting anything on the way. You have two hitpoints.
Press grab to continue.
Grab it--ohhhuohhuoh!! Oh my God!
AAAHAHAAA!
That ain't right!
THAT BOY AIN'T RIGHT! Oh, that boy ain't right! OHH!
That boy is every kind of weird!
RIP?!
JU-JUS-JUST an arm die, and you shed it off and grow a new one?!
I mean, I guess you have no problem growing the longest arm in the world!
Baby...
(creepy baby laughing)
Do not laugh at me like that, you freaky baby bitch!
(warped baby laughing)
(reading) You need to collect all the collectibles before grabbing the bottle--WHY??
Why is that a requirement??
Alright, I'm ready. Oh boy-ye-heheho...
(Markimoo being grossed out)
I don't know why this is necessary, but here we go.
SCOOBIDY-WHOOPDY! Uhh...
It's like 'Catch Your Chance', but somehow infinitely weirder.
SCUBLUBLOOLSCS uhuhuh...
Oh, man... it's like Mrs. Incredible's OTHER baby.
(creepy laughing)
Do not laugh at me like that, you FREAKY BABY!
What is that? (reading) Big, round objects with a blue outline can be pushed forward by ramming your hand into them.
Yeah, if you can even call that your hand.
Sure, let's go with 'ramming'. I'm whatever with this.
Wha--why... why is there... why is there a towel, fluttering in the wind?
Alright, whatever. Oops.
Well, that's not what I wanted--AHAHAHA OW!
Alright--uhbuh FUCK!
Ah--my fuckin' hand got EXPLODED!
All my baby bones got shattered on impact!
OK, so I think I need to come in from the OTHER angle here.
SHOOBIDOOP--well, that didn't work AT ALL
Hang on.
Wait--hang on.
I gotta--
Alright--it's like playing Slither
Slither.io!
FU-HU-HU-HUCK!
How are you supposed to do that?!
Oh, man, this is... this is a DOOZY!
It's like Slithare.io! Or SLITHER.io, as everyone else in the world calls it.
BUT NOT ME!
Oh, I was trying to get back!
I just need to get to the bottle over there, and I'll--oh, I get it now.
I was being dumb. Just shattering my baby bones on everything here.
(creepy laughing)
Oh, jeez. UHUHUH!
What is that--OH, GOD!
I thought that was HAIR!
What the fuck is wrong with this baby?!
THIS BABY IS NOT RIGHT!
(reading) Often you need to grab and pull objects with blue...glow...to solve puzzles. Press and hold 'grab' to start pulling back. Drop the item by letting go of the button.
Alright, sure.
I'm not sure I remember what the grab button was.
OH!!
It works like that, now, does it?
HUHUHA...
HAHA.. OK!
Alright...HHUHUHAHA
HAHAHA
I'd hate to meet the parents of the baby.
HERE WE GO!
What was with the breathing?!
What, were you getting impatient, baby?
ER-DOINK! EEEEEEEEE...
That's not what I wanted!
Oh, I know what I need to do. Okay.
So, what I need to do, is I need to get over here
Yea--yeah, that's the stuff.
(purring) DINK
HAHA!
HAHAHA!
AH, yes!
Mother, do you need help cleaning underneath the couch?
I could lend you a HAND!
HAHAHAHAHA!
(Markiplier dying)
This is so fucked up.
But I love it.
Is that a bottle of piss in the bottom right?
Ah, whatever. We're gonna gloss over that fact.
(reading) Some objects break down when dropped. Be careful when and where you drop them.
*smack smack smack* OKAY!
Grab it. FUCK! I didn't know I was coming from that angle!
I'm sorry!
EXCU-U-U-U-USE YOU!
I gotta make a bit of a journey over here because we gotta do a bunch of bullshit for some reason!
Excuse me while I...exact my revenge on my broken hand by dropping one of Mother's PRECIOUS items!
SCUSE! SCUSE!
Also, how do I have the strength?
How do I have the sheer manipulative strength
AS A BABY, to pick this shit up in the first place?
That's my point of contention in this.
It's like--I don't like the logic of THAT.
Oh, frick I forg--oh, no!
Oh, no, I FORGOT! AHH!
OWWWWWW!
I forgot to get the first one in the first place.
I forgot about that. Yeah, okay, alright.
Right, I'm gonna get that FIRST
You know, for being a freakish game from HELL, this is oddly relaxing.
Like, the music is nice, and it's a smooth, snake-like, penile motion.
You know, I think I can get behind this game.
And by get behind, I mean throw it down into the deepest hole and bury it forever, and then toss it into the pits of Hell.
So that it can burn for all eternity,
and I'll sacrifice it to the various gods.
Alright, let's try this a few more times.
WHAT THE FU-HUCK
IS WRONG WITH THAT BABY?!
That baby is not okay!
There's something horrible going on here--you know
when something is supposed to look normal
and, you know, it's supposed to be, like, masked by the niceties
of, oh, the DING-DONG xylophone?
But then you forget: THERE'S A FUCKIN' BABY
HERE, grabbing clams and shit!
And somehow, he's able to see this
That means he's got, like, eyeballs in his arm.
Ready with wha--oh, my God
I didn't read what I was supposed to do with that.
I don't know what I'm supposed to do.
I guess I'm supposed to grab this.
I'll grab it.
OHH! OUCH-KABIBBLES!
Oh, that's what that do.
OH, that's what that do.
HAAAA--oh, fuck.
Well, this ain't gonna go well.
Okay...well, I mean--oh, jeez...
Yeah, this ain't gonna go well.
Let's just SOAR into death! Slap myself in my own face!
AHHHHHH!
I was being a smarty-pants about this.
DAAAH--fuck. You can't make that turn.
Okay, so you can't do that
So, you have to do it in a certain order.
That's what I'm discovering here.
You have to do this first
SHOINK
And then you have to pull the other one
And let me go down here to pull this one
SOOP-okay.
OW!
But I got it...
And then...
With my slightly-- OH!
NO! I forgot about that one...
OH NO!
OW!
Why do the pacifiers make the bottle soft?
Alright, last time. We got this one.
GUUUUH--fucking you!
I don't know what this is, but, umm...
Okay.
I pulled this back before, and it
didn't seem to do nothing.
So I'm just assuming it does nothing.
Oh, okay!
Well, that was really, really, REALLY close quarters!
I still don't think it's gonna matter...
'Cause if I can't get through here...
No, I can cycle around, I just
can't get my poor baby hand broken again.
I don't think
YEEEEEEEEE--I
don't think that was the way I supposed to do it
but I did it, okay?
Shit, dude! Why was that so hard?
That was like OBSCENELY difficult
That was ridiculously donkiful.
I died twenty-one times one that one. That's an embarrassment.
Let me see if I could do better on the next one to redeem myself.
I mean, you didn't see all the horrible horridness
That was fuckin' bullshit
Ready? I don't know...
GRAB IT!
Well, baby's crawling around his own gosh darn thing here
so, I don't know what I'm trying to do.
Oh, the bottle's in the castle, is it? OHHH....
GADOONNSHKI
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOHHHHH...
AHHH!
ow.
So you gotta go for this one first.
No, no, still--see--how do you--how do you do that?
Okay, I think I know how
It's just like--it really does--it really does just want you to do very very, VERY precise tolerances here.
fucking fuck you!
Fuck you!
Can't even make it out of my own basket!
Why don't you just grab it? If you want it, just grab it!
It's right there. No one's stopping you.
Real tight. Real tight on this.
Real tight. Oh, yeah.
Oh, am I gonna be able to get back? I don't know!
We're gonna find out!
Yee--tight tight tight
Oh, Jesus! Oh, jeez!
Oh no Oh no Oh no--ahh,
FUCK!
Ooh, such a tight squeeze, tight squeeze, tight squeeze
Ooh, tight squeeze, okay.
TIIIIIGHT sqeeze
Oh, tight squeeze, okay
YES, okay!
Alright okay, ahhhhhhh!
I guess they didn't want to make it easy! They really didn't.
Oh, my God.
Okay, precision is a part of this
Either way, I think that's all I'm gonna play of this particular game here.
It is weird, it is funky, but I kinda like it.
If you're into this sorta puzzle aspect thing,
that they got going on here, you--oh, my GOD!
I don't wanna go to Grandma's! I don't wanna go!
so anyway, that is all for grab the bottle.
Thank you, everybody, so much for watching.
Let me know what you thought in the comments below, because
this is a weird one, but
this might appeal to some of you guys, so
Thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know what you thought in the comments
And, as always, I will see you in the next video! BUH-BYE!